einige der ersten galaxien im kosmos
haben deutlich heller beleuchtet als
bislang angenommen und diese entdeckung
der nasa könnte tatsächlich dazu
beitragen eines der ältesten ungelösten
rätsel der astronomie zu lüften konkret
geht es um die frage wer die
hauptakteure der sogenannten regen oni
sierung waren dieser wandel des
universums beendete das dunkle zeitalter
doch wodurch wurde das alles genau
ausgelöst klicks um science-fiction hier
gibt es täglich faszinierendes eines
videos abonniert den kanal nur dann und
nur dann verpasst er nicht herzlich
willkommen forschungsteams weltweit sind
sich einig dass die sogenannte
regionalisierung stattgefunden haben
muss eine neue epoche des kosmos die
ersten jungen sterne bildeten sich und
deren intensive strahlung ionisierte die
interstellaren wolken aus neutralem
wasserstoffgas das heißt die starke
strahlung shots elektronen aus den
atomen heraus sie wurden positiv geladen
damit war die voraussetzung für die
weitere entwicklung des kosmos gelegt
doch astronomie teams weltweit rätseln
seit langer zeit wann die ersten sterne
entstanden und diese regen oni sierung
begann schätzung zufolge passiert es
wohl wenige millionen jahre nach dem
urknall rund 150 millionen jahre
zudem ist unklar welche strahlenquellen
genau dafür sorgten dass das dunkle
zeitalter beendet wurde
wer also waren die hauptakteure dieser
region ii sierung dazu der
wissenschaftler stefan der boss von der
universität gent das ist eine der
größten offenen fragen der kosmologie
wir wissen dass die regionalisierung
passiert ist aber was hat sie aus gülle
zusammen mit seinem team ist dem barros
der lösung dieses rätsels jetzt wohl
einen entscheidenden schritt näher
gekommen
dafür haben die wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler 135 galaxien genauer
analysiert die wenige hundert millionen
bis eine milliarde jahre nach dem
urknall existierten
dafür nutzte das team um den bars daten
des spitzer weltraumteleskop der nasa
und das ergebnis ist überraschend und
zeigt dass die fachwelt sich in ihren
bisherigen annahmen geirrt hatte
denn anders als gedacht gibt es sehr
wohl erste galaxien
die extrem stark geleuchtet haben das
war bisher bezweifelt worden konkret
hatte das forschungsteam des spitzer
teleskop genutzt um die licht spektren
der galaxien in zwei bereichen des
infraroten lichts aufzuzeichnen
diese wellenlängen stehen nämlich für
diejenige strahlung die durch die
expansion des kosmos gedehnt wurde aber
im frühen kosmos noch sehr energiereich
und kurzweilig war eine premiere in
diesem forschungsbereich denn die
ionisierende strahlung einer solch
großen stichprobe an sternen ansammlung
wurde bislang noch nie untersucht und
die analyse hat sich gelohnt denn sie
offenbarte dass diese galaxien deutlich
mehr ionisierende strahlung erzeugten
als experten und expertinnen es bislang
angenommen hatten dazu heißt es in der
studie
und das für diese galaxien m ist der
wert der ionisierenden portionen
produktion ist mindestens dreimal höher
als der kanonische wert kanone steht
dabei für den regeln entsprechend das
heißt dass der vergleich mit den
heutigen gegenstücken dieser galaxien
zeigt dass selbst die damals
vermeintlich durchschnittlichen galaxien
mehr ionisierende strahlung erzeugten
als solcher galaxien heute erzeugen
würden das team schlussfolgert daraus
dass solche strahlungs intensiven
galaxien in der frühzeit des universums
keine seltenheit waren sondern in
größerer anzahl vorhanden waren eine
wirklich bahnbrechende erkenntnis das
rätsel wäre so gelöst dazu pascal oesch
einer der autoren
diese ergebnisse sind ein weiterer
schritt darin das rätsel der kosmischen
regierung zu lösen wir wissen jetzt sagt
die physikalischen bedingungen in diesem
frühen galaxien deutlich anders waren
als bei galaxien heute heißt nämlich im
klartext dass diese anfänglichen sternen
am sammlung doch als hauptakteure der
realisierung fungiert haben könnten
schon bald könnten wir schlauer sein und
zwar durch das james webb
weltraumteleskop ein supertalent im
infraroten bereich das sehr genau und
weit ins all gucken kann
mysteriöse struktur im weltall saurons
auge anklicken anschauen und neugier zu
abonnieren richtig cooler kanal meine
empfehlung bis dann bleibt dran